I want to bring those who have wronged
me to justice and all those who have
wronged me are right here I will begin
with Ser Gregor Clegane who killed my
sister's children and then raped her
with their blood
still on his hands before killing her
too
there will be your champion
while Danny kind of forgot about the
iron fleet and Euron's forces can you
read the cupbearer can read better than
you see I overestimated you look the
lives of four kings
grand maester Cates history of the
reigns of daeron the young dragon baelor
the blessed a book every King should
read now if the war is won we should all
find time for wisdom you're a dragon be
a dragon
see it Negro that's all you had to say
what if I told you that you can't hurt
the newcomers
[Music]
if you'll have me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is there too many of them what are we
going to do
[Music]
and who has a better story than brand
the broken lord varys i Daenerys of
House Targaryen first of my name
sentence you to die
dracarys
[Music]
the golden company 20,000 men horses
elephants I believe America vo Doral
heiress was mahogany on toss the Prince
he was promised will bring the dawn of
Denison while I was training to be a
faceless man with the faces I can choose
imagine become someone else speaking
their voice living their skin relevant l
is it the Lord led you come back for a
reason Stannis was not the prince was
promised that someone has to be
[Music]
[Music]
so for this part of the video I was
gonna show off some funny Varys coughing
merchandise like phone cases and shirts
however I didn't really like the designs
that I got for them I essentially just
went on Fiverr and hired some merch
designers to make various coughing and
here they are I personally don't really
like them that much and they're kind of
low quality so I don't want to sell it
I'm not really taking this seriously
anyways because I'm doing it for the
memes but if you guys actually want some
Varys coughing merch then I'll go more
high end and have an artist make a
portrait of him or something but yeah
hopefully I just like the video and I
could possibly make a third but it's
full of memes for Game of Thrones